judd apatow and Pete Holmes promoting
season three of crashing I've been
seeing posters for it in the subway yeah
you know holding your it's a great
poster they gave you well your call yeah
floating in the artist
oh you all right it was like were you
jumping what we do in PT will you jump
how high off the ground where you about
as high as it looks but you know
everything in that photo is uh-oh
unprofessional with the adjust for the
friend you know they put in the shadow
they put in the spotlight
what am i a guy who just found out
Photoshop is a thing actually my feet
are some kind of antigravity chamber
that they shot every year there's a
moment where we go what's the poster for
crashing and I have to sit in all these
meetings and go how do I have a picture
of Pete's head that makes people want to
work that makes people want to buy birth
control do you sit there and as it's
like season three now you know the show
is a big show now do you have to go like
what we have to put a little bit more
production value in the poster well it's
think as you go most people drive by the
poster so the only way that you know
it's the show is if Pete's head is
really big yeah that that's a Jed
philosophy obviously you think of the 40
year old virgin think of knocked-up yeah
I see other friends that have chosen
they do these posters where they're like
one person in the crowd and I'm like you
shows not big enough
the name of the show huge you huge and
the time huge none of this like you'll
find us
no you won't yeah you don't want too
many shows you're less clear this is
clearly your show you know that people
have had that conversation where they're
the star of the show but really it's a
whole cast and they go what about just
my face on the poster and somebody's got
to be like it's not about you well when
you have to put like seven people on the
poster people don't know what the show
is right we have that with movies where
like I think we have to show everyone or
they'll be mad thanks the poster
terrible what do you think I'm with the
supreme is you think that they suggested
that Diana Ross put her name
guys I get RT as such loyal fans
I can't tweet about the show without
10000 people 10,000 being like where's
Adi
Marathi like he'll be in the trailer and
they'll be like Marathi I'm going to
trailer yeah it needs to be more Adi are
you guys worried about him because
everybody was tweeting like apparently
all these gay get help and recently like
how you guys concern when you said that
I was like did something happen last
known world of friends have already is
unfortunate but yeah we're concerned
about RT for sure his nose looks awful
yeah
and he's in pain and he's suffering he's
you know he's trying to get sober but
fighting the good fight and it's really
hard and for people who spend a lot of
time with him yeah you get an up-close
look at the horrors of addiction I got a
very specific RT though so I'm not like
maybe the best pretty like Quinn or so
these people that have known already for
like a really long time maybe you have
you know naughty long-term well yeah so
I bet you would you know you have more
of a sense of the flavor the RT that I
know and I'm not just saying this to
help his career was very very
professional I used to joke I was like
where's the I thought you'd be throwing
up dry cigarettes by now but he'd come
in and know his lines nobody's funnier
yeah
kills scenes I've said many times I
think a big reason wouldn't you agree
our pilot got picked up was because of
his performance oh yeah in the pilot
which he improvised and at the end
everyone applauded like Nick Nolte it
really what I've never seen we've done
three seasons now no matter what I do no
applause Artie Artie got the crew to
apply well so he's an interesting cuz he
does when he's functioning he's great
like yeah show up he would do Howard and
I was doing ona and I would be getting
here exactly the same time as him and
I'm like he does heroin and I'm not
showing up five minutes Artie we're
getting here at the same time no I know
we playing with a pretty big hand yeah
and he's still winning was is it was his
nose like going through the process as
you were shooting well you gotta have a
nose update his nose was different right
but it would be different every day I'm
not trying to be funny it was a
different note but that's why I'm asking
when you're trying to do a show and
you're like I'm not necessarily shooting
the scenes in order but your nose key
from the scene there was knows
continuity issues again not trying to be
funny it's just a fact and and my heart
breaks for already
it's something that you'd sometimes have
to you know fix or talk about or you
know will work around or work it around
you from behind over-the-shoulder do you
talk about it on the show or do you just
try to deal with it behind the scenes
and you didn't talk about the nose on
the show yeah and you know we tried to
talk about what he's going through on
the show so last season we did a whole
episode and it was basically about Pete
realizing how bad Artie's addiction is
and the fact that no matter how much he
tries to help it doesn't work and it's
really up to Artie to and I find the
strength to do it and already wrote it
you know you know you improvise and
talked about it and was very brave about
showing how painful his world can be and
it was a really important episode
because you know Artie was showing
people like yes is awful yeah and and if
I tell you the truth about it maybe
there's someone out there when they're
in that moment where they might try
something to do something they might go
I don't know I don't want to experience
what he's going through he wishes he
could put it down more than anything
yeah he always says it is the worst
moment of his life was the first time
that he tried heroin than it was and he
kind of why that would lead to he wishes
he could take it back and he says the
second he did it in his mind he went I'm
in big trouble because that could mean
it I think everyone feels that way about
heroin know most people I'm guessing who
get hooked on it don't do heroin ago
this sucks like it's probably amazing
there is a way to get off it though I
mean if he wanted to there is a way it's
very difficult but there is a way to
stop it you also I mean it is a disease
that that addictive personality mixed
with the heroin I think is what we're
dealing with just because I I'm just
gonna tell you full disclosure it was a
facebook video but it was interesting
was based on a TED talk they were
talking about addiction and how Facebook
video based on it yeah reading an
article
six-second vine summarizing an article
yes but they were talking about the
phenomenon of people that need
painkillers strong painkillers that are
given oxycontin and oxycodone and all
those different ones oxy kitten you had
a P - a doubt it's a line from one of
his movies anyway they don't get
addicted and and it sort of broke the
myth the idea that if you do it once
that you're addicted so it's not just
the magical substance it is huh like
it's absolutely super super super super
addictive and don't don't just take my
word for it there's plenty of research
on them so you're saying this video was
letting people know if you don't have an
addictive personality try some heroin it
actually is video and Joe we got to ask
you - I have to ask you as a comedian
yes please the tweets about Lois yes yes
that was you I literally didn't know
about it until the next day because I've
taken twitter off my phone and I don't
one have you were you getting flack for
that or key what can you walk us through
like just what was what happened there
with your with your you're thinking was
it well I think we all want Louie to
talk about what he's going through in a
way that is you know in word searching
lets us know what he makes of it all
because there's so much to say about it
and that's what you know when someone
says I'm gonna go away and try to think
about this I didn't look at it in the
right way before so when they return and
they don't say a word about it that's
kind of weird because that's what we
were hoping that you would do is say hey
I kind of get it now I'm trying to do
right by these people I'm trying to
evolve as a person so he's not saying
that at all he's just punching down at
you know kids who got shot at or whose
friends died and you go what what's
really your what's your angle here if
you're making fun of trans people and I
just thought to myself I know we all
talk about everything you do it all the
time I've never watched you and thought
like oh god you know but if you're the
guy trying to say to the wind I hurt
people and I I get
I get it your comeback material
shouldn't be mocking kids whose friends
were murdered yes you know I understood
do you think and this is just a question
that as performances committees were
working stuff out punching up punching
down I mean everyone punches down once
in a while Carlin did it with you know
anorexia rich constant one eight five
like just the context I think what he's
saying is like it's a heartbreaker when
one of the best comedians that ever
lived
came back from this tragedy and instead
of addressing it like Pryor did when he
lit himself on fire he just came back
and was like okay nothing's changed
we're like [ __ ] let us have to
change you have to show us change it's
not just important for you it's
important for everybody that's watching
there's a lot of scumbags out there that
could be redeemed and that's not his job
as a comedian his job as a comedian is
again I know what you're saying but
that's not our job comedians we would
have I think you sort of lose that past
if you do atrocious that how do you
think you I don't even think you need a
prior didn't lose the past probably
[ __ ] pulled a gun on his wife he
didn't lose the past I talked about I
mean at least he didn't underwear he
talked about it with humility but what I
was saying was Louis working out a bit
and I might say it was in the bid is
evidence that he's not taking the time
to reflect isn't that heartbreak I'm not
look I don't even agree with that I'm
with you that that he can talk about
what everyone should take anybody's card
away so that's not that's not be unclear
about that I'm just saying when
something like this happens especially
if this didn't happen to Louie like
let's say was another comedian I would
be like what's Louie gonna say about it
I would look to Louie to laugh to heal
and to find some catharsis through him
and he's acting like it didn't happen
maybe but Louis maybe that's just to sit
whatever reason he's making that
decision I might handle it differently
or you might handle it differently but
he's handling it like that but does that
make him like less than because he's
doing a bit that is offensive like it
was an offense he's not job is not to
teach a lesson his job is to pose and be
funny our job is not to have a higher
motive behind a joke we can but that's
not what we're supposed and isn't it
isn't it two different criticisms to
criticize for not addressing what you
should be addressing because I do agree
that Louis should be talking about this
thing that we all know and then it would
make his life easier I think if he did
but then to be critical of the material
that he's doing instead that feels like
it's two separate I think it's all part
one organism which is we all looked up
to him he inspired us he pushed us to
work hard he pushed us to think deeper
he represented something to people and
so when you come back from hurting
people and what you're talking about on
stage just hurts other people we're
allowed to say publicly oh he's still
hurt it's kind of [ __ ] up how come
we're allowed to I mean he doesn't have
a right to not be criticized it's not
like he's in a bubble and we're supposed
to be secretive about his act he's on a
public stage he's getting paid and so
the opposite could be that you go I'm
just not gonna say anything
but somewhere out there and I know this
is something that like a lot of
comedians don't care about somewhere out
there there are kids whose friends are
dead and they're trying to get over it
and this guy they probably used to
really look up to is [ __ ] on them
saying you're not interested and that's
and it's helpful to them for someone to
go you know what [ __ ] that I don't agree
with what he's saying there's nothing
wrong with saying that we should keep
working on his act but that crowd is
kissing his ass so hard and so much that
material is so weak and from such a
demented point of view that why
shouldn't he hear from certain people
like hey Louie you're kind of out of
tune right now and maybe it helps Louie
for somebody other than that kiss-ass
crowd to go
why are they just as crowd though if
they were just laughing at what they
thought like Holland that he took
something it was he took the angle of
being obnoxious Louie's absurdist
everybody'll point a guy is making again
I haven't talked to him about this is
hey these guys were in the strategy why
does that make them qualified to speak
for us that's the point of view that
people do have whether it's nice or not
he takes it to whatever degree and is
vicious about it he takes the mean angle
on it that's but Louie's always been it
he hold on he's always said stuff like
I'm gonna diarrhea [ __ ] in your mother's
mouth he was on a plane years ago
tweeting about Sarah Palin about
[ __ ] in Sarah Palin's mouth about
talking about her [ __ ] kid like
little later that he did delete it but
he still but everyone knows that that's
how his mind works where he'll take it
to this absurdist obnoxious brutal point
of view he's always done that is a
quality allowed to debate the value why
are people all of a sudden well yes
comedians though because I find out that
Michael Jackson Malloy
children suddenly pretty young thing
means something different but I don't
like George Carlin was a good guy so
when he talked about how he wanted the
world to be lit on fire we we kind of
understood that his point was we all
need to wake up a little bit because the
world's going to [ __ ] so he would root
on all the negative so you're saying it
was a point it's this Richard Pryor
wasn't a this guy if uber has like some
questionable practice remember when that
happened yeah we're all like well we're
gonna delete Ober I guess they figured
it out there was nothing wrong with uber
you're just saying like well we found
something out about the practical are we
allowed to debate it I've been part of
it I you know you feel this with
comedians that we're all supposed to not
discuss the material not true like did
us talking about it I think is great was
I don't feel disgusted I'm not saying I
had nothing against people who were
offended by it or who thought the bits
stuck it's all fair but as comics to
look at a comic working a bit out and
act like we don't know what they're
doing like a lot of times you work
through different angles of a bit this
is not a finished piece we put out so
you're not thinking about the other part
of it and this is because you know what
would you want tuned into it I've done
these benefits with shooting victims
right so I've sat with like a parent
who's like my kid is dead and she tells
me the story about how her kid got shot
for trying to you know save his
girlfriend and I met a lot of people got
over getting shot in Vegas and then oh
and all these place I've looked into
their eyes and so it's not abstract
you're talking comedy theory there are
people this isn't like you know like a
vague joke he's talking about people
whose names we know we know Cameron and
David and Emma we know who they are so
give him a [ __ ] break at some what I
choose being a human being over like
comedy theory we could talk about
everything we're working on [ __ ] so
tomorrow the bid will get better
that's fine but those kids are reading
all about this guy they probably looked
up to [ __ ] on them you know I got it
your your back on this I I want you guys
to get better I don't give a [ __ ] about
Louise
so what other jokes should people like
this now you're getting into an area of
kudo of course it was a real tragedy no
one's denying it was horrible or that do
it was there was disgusting what
happened or their gun
that's all very accurate but I know
people that have put guns in their own
mouths and so should I not make fun of
suicide I actually don't think it's it
would be your point of making fun of
suicide if you if you came here from an
angles like you're just weak yeah it
might be [ __ ] up and somebody might go
like yeah that's a terrible joke and why
can't someone tell you it's a tarrant
say it's a terrible joke but it's the
idea that well this is a real tragedy so
he shouldn't be working it like maybe
that's not the final angle he will
settle on I don't know but those kids
don't know that it's out there so when
you do a joke you're only worried about
the people who might be affected by the
joke Janeiro's our quarters are a lot
but should I tweet hey guys I think
Louie's gonna adjust his angle so don't
worry about the fact that even though
you almost not he says your unknown oh
but let me ask you when you do a movie
and I know you improv a lot in film you
like which is great did you allow people
to improv sir would you want all of
those dailies released as the finished
product like for instance I'm sure
people have said things whether it was
on the set or in a film improv it
because you allow that that were
tasteless or that were rude or that
didn't work in the scene would you want
all that to come out and have your final
product judged on these moments that may
or may not have made the final cut this
is a work product this is I know but you
could say that forever
we all work on our acts for a decade but
he is in a public place he is being but
hey I don't think it's about the
material he uploaded it was not meant to
be to be for public use meant for that
audience I I agree with what you're
saying and I think one of the things
that's important about Santa is I if you
did that joke I don't think it would be
as big of a story you know what I'm
saying what we're dealing with and
you're right it's not his job but
whether or not he likes it he's sort of
representing something how are men going
to respond to the me to move and how are
they going to respond when they were you
know caught or confessed to doing
something a lot of people are picking up
messages on that whether or not it's his
job and whether or not he likes it
so I think what you're hearing is some
of the disappointment that the hilarious
unbelievable comedian Louie when it
happened when it came out I was like in
a year he's gonna get onstage and he's
gonna blow us away and instead he's
doing this if Rock did that joke I'd be
like yeah I'd be here screaming red in
the face like it's his right you're
absolutely right I've said things
riffing in Jed's show
I'm like don't release that and it was
[ __ ] up that somebody did release this
and it's a violation of the artistic
contract I understand that
I'm just saying whether he likes it or
not what's egregious to me and worth
discussing is how Louis as a
representation of the whole thing is not
using it as opportunity for healing I
understand he doesn't have to you can
say that economic who [ __ ] up he's
just a comedian who [ __ ] up I'm not
saying it was right we're not in poor
taste or that he should have done that
but people are acting like he has this
responsibility I'm not acting I'm
wishing he would look at it like hers
but people aren't people aren't he
doesn't have to you're right he can be
an [ __ ] if he wants to be nice always
taking that angle as a comic that's what
I'm saying it's not this is not new I
think we're saying is that and you can
correct me if I'm wrong but that Louie
could have gotten away with it before
because you guys are like he's a good
guy you can trust them we know Norton's
a good guy he can get away with this if
you buy these jokes I would I would be
on this show going like Jim you can do
whatever you want but you need Lulu you
need Louie to make you as an audience
member feel okay with what you heard
about him through his comedy before even
back to I'm saying wouldn't I think we
can all agree maybe wouldn't it have
been great if the guy who maybe unfairly
became the symbol of this whole thing
used his incredible talent as a writer
and a performer to deliver some sort of
message like he always does only
comedian sorry why is the only comedian
who have to deal with this [ __ ]
like why do actors never have to go back
and explain what they've said in films
you know I don't hear this they didn't
write it because then the writers never
held accountable but why can't DiCaprio
say and use the type of stuff in Django
and everyone is fine with it but if a
comic comes from a [ __ ] angle or a mean
angle with the goal of being funny all
of a sudden oh my god like Louie was not
writing a blog making a declarative
statement of fact he was not standing on
a balcony going all kidding aside this
is how I feel he took what was arguably
a very mean angle on a very sensitive
and sad subject and made people laugh
and then you look at it like well the
audience over there were kiss-ass is
instead of going that was a heart that
those people that are
don't care any less about shot people
than people who were sitting in this
room to laughing at darkness is who they
all but they all care about what
happened in parkland and yet for some
reason they laughed at his angle at it
that doesn't make them kiss-ass as maybe
the material is just working and people
are furious at Louis but like Sam said I
think it's two different issues maybe
hydrants it is two separate issues and I
think it's more of a heartbreak than
anything I'm just like me personally I'm
with you he's a comedian we all have no
one tells me what to do flowing through
our veins [ __ ] off I'm going off-roading
you can't touch me I'm saying it's a
missed opportunity and it broke my heart
I'm like please Louie do stand-up about
Louie no one can do this and no and if
he did and it's not his job if he did
show growth if he did show that he was
listening if he showed the process of
wrestling and maybe he still will I'm
not saying he has to run around you know
and I'm saying I would like it as a tan
you would like it yeah and he has the
right to work on some fucked-up [ __ ] and
I think that's an important part of
stand-up nobody I don't want censorship
I don't want anything like that I'm just
saying it hurts me I wish and I'm still
maybe I'm an optimist I'm holding out
that maybe he will turn it around
because I don't think this is the right
move right now but then they jumped
right into shoe well look what he said
about Asian people look what he said
about black people look at me said my
treasure on finding my old age or the
old HBO clip with Gervase and Seinfeld
it's like now people are just gonna go
over his old work and pick it apart like
they're appalled and shocked instead of
realizing people are he was a genius for
all these years and then because this
happens and again people have the right
to not be fans and go [ __ ] him we don't
like ask you something it's like when
someone like dice Wright is going out we
were talking about this off-mike
Jeselnik dice this is an important
corner of comedy doesn't all have to be
me we don't all have to be talking about
bubbles and [ __ ] unicorn
I don't always much rather be here than
me you know I'm saying I understand I'm
not like an idiot going away everything
should be whoa okay I don't believe that
I believe there's different parts of the
human psyche they all need
representation and laughing at your
[ __ ] up material like some of your
darker stuff is catharsis when we find
out the person doing it is struggling
with something I kind of just want to go
can we
pause on moving forward in the way
you've been moving and just maybe adapt
again he doesn't have to it's what I'm
expressing is a disappointment that he's
not going let me show you before I go
back to that stuff let me show you that
I can grow a little bit and listen like
he promised he would in his epaulet
maybe it's hard again I don't know I
have not honestly have not asked Louie
this maybe it's hard because you know
that anything you say could be leaked
out there so if you start talking about
this material and it seems like you're
being flippant about it or if it seems
like you don't care about like I I don't
know maybe he's just stuck and doesn't
know how to do it I don't think that he
may not understand the gravity of what
he did and there's a there's a defiance
in talking about trans people and saying
Asian people have small penises and
making fun of shooting victims there's a
projection of his own pain and his own
frustration with his situation and you
feel it in his selection of material I
mean you know if any of us got in
trouble for something and we were
writing the new set and you said well
what should I talk about in light of how
everyone perceives me the choice of his
targets and subjects is super-weird yeah
and I don't think there's anything wrong
with the world going I think you gotta
adjust the little bit reminds them of
being abused by somebody and then that
person acting like it didn't have well I
believe that I think that that there's
there's like there's there's levels to
the whole thing like I think that I was
a fan like I listen to part of the set I
didn't listen to the whole thing because
I don't want to listen to a whole hour
of bootleg you didn't want him to step
on your material but like I had no
problem with any of his jokes because I
was like that's Louie and I thought that
the sort of casting him is now an all
trite comic that's gonna play red states
is like what are we doing in your
politics but as a fan I do find myself
there is this part of me that's just
waiting for what we all want to be
addressed to be addressed like Louie's
the one guy who's gonna be able to I
think he went out of address I know but
also I think you know and this is all
hey I love a good debate about if jokes
are good or bad I I think he should
perform I have no doubt in the next year
and a half he'll be at Madison Square
Garden doing
three shows in a row so this whole like
Lois struggling thing you will make
eighty million dollars on the next tour
okay this all lands with him triumphant
in some way maybe not with everybody but
that's where it lands but in the
meantime when you're somebody that's
hurt people it's weird to think your
subjects should be people who are
hurting you know trans people they
commit suicide they get murdered at a
crazy rate so it's not really the
moments ago I'm put out by the fact that
you want to be called by a certain name
yeah a lot of people have done that bit
by the way so it's not even that
interesting a bit the medium changes his
bit went on that Wolcott I think he did
about calling me the I'm a location and
the punchline on I'm a location it made
me laugh out loud it was a hilarious I
don't even I people okay so you know and
I get it and we all have that in our
lives are like okay we're adjusting to
something and so I guess Louie's doing
that it's hard to adjust to a woke
country type of thing but also there are
people who are like I'm getting murdered
my friends all could be suicide maybe
it's not the moment to call me a jackass
cuz I want respect no I don't believe
that I I mean I of course if they if
life was that literal sure but then if
you made a movie about trans people
being murdered nobody would have a
problem with it if Stephen King killed
trans people in his books nobody would
have a problem with it so as artists as
comedians the only way we can address
something without being virtuous
signaling idiots is to try to be funny
with it however we see fit so I like
barbarism and comedy I like horrible
barbers I'd love to learn it makes me
laugh and it has never once made me look
at a subject differently than I looked
at it as a human being and no comedians
ever made me look at something
differently as a human being so Louise
being horrible about parkland won't make
me feel one ounce less empathy for those
people that that happen to know those
are real people realize about it no no
I'm not even disagreeing with that but I
talk about 9/11 I talk about a lot
walnuts do so where does the where is
the line where there's real feelings and
real peace we not talk about cancer I
think we're dealing with new lines
though I think I've made my point maybe
I should shut up but I
it's different because it's Louie in
light of what is what's happening not
that he can't do it because you're
absolutely right one of the problems is
we're all on the record and one of the
problems is everything's being recorded
yeah and even as being a fan of
something we're losing a way to enjoy
our shadow selves which you know the
part of our psyche that's dark and there
was a time and I've said this many times
it used to be an Amsterdam and you'd
duck into a bar and you have a glass of
absinthe and watch the comedian let's
say the most [ __ ] up terrible things
you've ever heard and you'd laugh your
ass off and you'd leave feeling
catharsis cuz that's one of the human
needs it's being in your basement with
your friends at a sleepover and saying
the things you're not supposed to say
that's a human need and I understand it
I'm saying it changes when everyone's
looking at you and going that's the guy
who assaulted people and again it's not
his job but wouldn't it be nice if he
would would you Jim if something came
out about you would you talk about it
before you and probably something I've
already talked about but if something
did happen to you I have a feeling that
you would address it you'd self
disparage yourself you put yourself down
you'd make some jokes about it you'd
even make fun of how it's [ __ ] that
people are overreacting you'd find a way
to make us laugh at the other side
brilliant and then the 911 stop order
matters order can do those parkland
jokes I and people can not like them and
I can not like them that's fine
but like let's let's not forget the
elephant but the process the often in
the room too is that it's it's a work in
progress
I stand up you don't see a singer just
swish throwing through verses in
progress was different work but don't
over now how do you know he's not gonna
get there and maybe the bottom line
meaning the development you saying you
should develop an assertion about the
the stuff that is timely he's saying he
should develop develop that maybe he
doesn't want to develop that so he's got
till he's put on stage a little while I
think the more question was why the hell
isn't Louie using those goddamn cell
phone bags the Dave Chappelle has why is
anybody reporting he says right now can
be recorded some again and I truly am
speculating us maybe he's not gonna talk
about it or maybe he's put together a
certain amount of material he wants to
get his legs back and then wants to go
out and do it or maybe
wants to be filming when he finally
talks about that stuff or maybe he wants
to find a way to be I don't know yeah
but as far as judging that's like
watching somebody in the gym I know but
but Jim is there and maybe it's just cuz
you haven't been exposed to it when you
meet people whose friends have died when
you maybe you've been shot and they're
[ __ ] up for life and you and you have
a real empathy and when you have kids
and your kids are doing active shooter
drills and they're terrified and it's
ruin their entire childhoods the fact
that they really believe any day they
can get murdered but if somebody does a
joke and say it's even in process it's
fine to say hey that was kind of [ __ ]
up yeah I hope he punches up the bit I
hope or I hope he expands the bit and
and you know bill burr style comes in
from every angle where it's meaningful
but in the moment when he hurts those
kids I care more about those kids
knowing like people care about you then
I care about like I got to protect
Louise bubble of comedy was not about
Louise bubble it's not about Louise or
his bubble I'm not gonna drug that's not
what my issue was not about Louie like
he said Louise still worth more money
than Oliver making my career it was
about the idea of a comic working out a
bit and other comedians acting like
we're not sure that what is this process
that you're doing and to answer your
question no I haven't met a lot of
shooting victims but I know a lot of
people committed suicide I know a lot of
people have died of AIDS and I know a
lot of people who've got cancer and all
of those are subjects that I will
address so the whole personalization of
it it's you know with all due respect is
slightly manipulative because we all
have a hand in tragedy that we talk
about mean we all have an attachment to
tragedy that we talk about you know I
know women who've been raped and it's
still a subject that there's no subject
that wouldn't be on the table to me as a
comedian that is acceptable to talk
about every son never offended about
like Gilbert Godfried doing you know
tidal wave jokes or I I want only with
you but if Gilbert Godfried was revealed
as someone who actually hurt people
I believe the context of him making
those jokes changes you understand that
it isn't it possible that I agree with
you that like barbarism if I wasn't sick
would be high fiving right now yes
barbarism is important to express an art
and they like they get the [ __ ] out of
that like in Germany like this painting
is all black it represent you know yeah
yeah understand we're kind of struggling
with that it changed the me
matters who's saying it matters and
again he doesn't have to address it but
wouldn't it be great if he did so I
would love to see him do it just as a
comic and as a friend like your empathy
that maybe is gonna do it later maybe he
will and this is not even about louis
c.k it's the idea that because it's not
just Louis who is having people come
about Louie Anderson's microphone I
could see it's the idea of just the way
people are viewing comics and what we
say on stage and then because he [ __ ]
up and you know he had what happened
happen he jerked over all of a sudden
now everybody's coming out of every
angle all of a sudden the outrage that
outrage was not there when he was
talking about Sarah Palin or diarrhea
[ __ ] and somebody's mother's mouth
hailing it was people it was yes well no
he died the speech because of one person
soldiers I think it's Trump I think we
had Trump with the [ __ ] grabbing we had
all of this like aggression rightful
aggression that we didn't have anywhere
to put right so where can we put it
we're gonna if we can't affect over that
gate into the White House will affect
ourselves it's gonna happen before a
powerhouse I think it's been happening
before I think it's a directory react to
trauma you think it may be the reaction
the sped things up but again I think
it's more social media I think if
Hillary was the president would still be
having Americans are exactly the same it
had nothing to do with Trump we are the
same people we like getting each other
no I like attacking publicly but who
else because of this political
correctness like there's so many
comedians talking about so many things
and so many different ways just because
I want to know like who's really taking
a hit right now like what what Kannur
McDonald almost lost his Netflix show
not apologizing the right way mm-hmm oh
yeah his pressed to her became an
apology to one thing or something people
are going back and grabbing old audio
from 2011 he said the and so every comic
you Kevin Hart loss the Kevin Hart lost
the Oscars
what so yeah yeah sorry man goodbye DVR
but do you understand so you're saying
who's taking the hit yeah everybody
everybody is getting hit on everyone is
censoring themselves in a new
I think it is I don't think movies are
no I don't think authors are comedians
you know I went on stage one night and I
did a lot of Trump jokes in Boston the
Wilburn and I got this great review in
Boston and then Breitbart picked out all
the Trump jokes or wrote a very anti Jud
article with all the the quotes making
it sound like you know this epic dark
rant and then the next day I just have
death threats at my office and they're
posting dark stuff on all the my social
media and stuff like that so I got a you
know a taste of okay this is what it's
like when you when you speak your mind
but my reaction to it wasn't I got a cut
all the jokes it really was okay there
was maybe one joke there that I thought
yeah maybe that pushed a hair too far
but but that is the reality right now
we're on stage every performance is
public every performance can be debated
and revealed we can't stop that part of
it but like when Quinn put out his book
the coloring book he just said you know
you just have to be able to stand behind
what you say you have to kind of have to
mean what you say even if you're working
it out that you're you know your ideas
that you've thought through in some way
but we're not even part of a
conversation because everyone says they
want the conversation no we don't Megan
Kelly again she was not doing well but
they can her for asking what is pretty
much a dumb question in a racial
discussion yeah so we don't want the
conversation area but you understand but
that's still what they use we don't want
an open and honest discussion we want
people parroting what we think that's
that's what people want because people
and also to address the Trump issue
you're right there is a lot of Trump
fans that are gonna be [ __ ] dicks
about it but in our business we all know
that attacking Trump and coming at it
from that angle even if you get flag is
not going to hurt you in our business
especially as much as attacking senators
is not going to hurt you in our business
let me ask you a question so if fluey is
you know he's punching down I don't like
saying punching down even especially I
don't like using that I don't think
comedians are our goal is not to punch
in any direction it's to be funny is to
punch however we feel like punching in
that moment okay so Louise picking
subjects where he's he's making jokes
about a lot of people who are
struggling or victims sure any does
their jokes right so and I think about
this in the moment so he does these
jokes I know the everyone's gonna write
about it I know these kids are gonna
read it they are real people this didn't
happen a very long time ago right what
is the alternative is the alternative
for the whole world to go let's not say
anything cuz Louie might make it better
and to be completely silent on those
ideas no the alternative is to go this
is a stand-up comedy performance and the
goal is to make people laugh and
comedians come from whatever angle they
want to come from in the moment and it's
not an important thing whatever angle he
comes from whether he's being nice or
mean who gives a [ __ ] it doesn't change
anything he's just trying to make people
laugh that's how I look at it with jokes
it's again the higher motive doesn't
mean anything to me because I don't look
at that joke or look at one that has a
very positive spin which there's plenty
of that and and fine either one has any
more merits in the overall scheme of
things a good joke is a good joke
Patrice said it about me talking about
good jokes and bad jokes they come from
the same place they're born from the
same place a vicious joke that bombs and
a brilliant smart joke that kills with a
with a an empathetic angle clean both
comes from the same place comedians not
why can't comedians be debated and
reviewed they can be good because that's
really ultimately all it is Louie's not
going anywhere he's performing you're
right you know like aren't we allowed to
say yeah that was that was a brilliant
thing they've all done that with Louie
aren't we allowed to go like wow these
are these are pretty bad joke it's
always someone else's apartment said
this was someone else's stuff like no
comedian has ever come out or any
performer and said here's what I've been
saying that I shouldn't say not one
person has ever done that it's always
here's what you're saying that I don't
like here's what you're saying that
isn't walk here's what you're saying
that's wrong when's the last time
comedians were also [ __ ] self we were
all so introspective and mindful artists
when's the last time a comedian came out
and outed himself and said this is what
I've been doing good thing like if Eddie
Murphy came out today and said there are
some jokes on my specials that looking
back on I'm not proud of that shows who
I was at the moment but ya know those I
can't stand behind them anymore I think
people would be for real I mean material
in the
moment like why how come no comments
coming out going wow I'm saying this now
and it's wrong or I'm not saying it's
always we always seem like we have the
perfect balance of taking horrible stuff
and making it funny but we always will
find somebody else to criticize but it's
never what we're saying that we come out
and I'll you understand what I'm saying
like you're gonna say this about Louis
or Louie will say it about you but
you're not going to come out and go hey
this material I'm doing is shitty and I
shouldn't be doing it it's cruel do you
think the way the criticism is being
taken is also a part of it the fact that
like you'll tweet out you know a whole
bunch of tweets about Louie and the
issue is that it's not taken like I'm
just Jud and I'm talking to some peers
and we're debating this thing right now
it reads as Judd Apatow big name in
comedy and people treat it like a press
release where it's like and I don't
think that's even how you would have
intended it but I honestly as a you know
no one's a bigger fan of comedy than me
and I like all the darkest stuff but on
some level on a human level that has
nothing to do with all the comedy rules
I just feel like it's more important to
say to those kids and to trans people
hey you're suffering I care more about
you than this right I think that's more
important to me and I get it you know
you could say the same thing about
should you you know about all sorts of
different cancer suicide yeah but also
it's a very fresh thing so I understand
everything you're saying and for the
most part I agree but I do think when
you've hurt people the rules slightly
change people are paying attention to do
you have empathy do you understand how
people suffer do you understand how your
choices in life make people suffer and
that's the context of watching him
perform now whether he likes it or not
that's you know what we're we're looking
at if Charlie Rose had a new show right
now and all of his guests were like 19
year old interns we'd be like weird like
why would he go with that he doesn't
have to but he could use it as a memory
and where he will I don't know if he
will or not to be realized I would like
to see him just I love Louie and I and I
do love him as a comic so I would love
to see him talk about it or write it I
don't know if he will or not I love when
you when cancer suicide I was like Jim
just gave us his Netflix password
absolutely my next book this is what I
did here's how I think I became the
person who would
that here's what I was thinking at the
time why I thought it was okay here's
how it felt to find out that I was wrong
and that I was looking at it wrong it
would be one of the great insightful
comedy pieces and I have to say I would
be surprised if in the next two years he
doesn't attempt to do that at the same
time I wouldn't hammer the trans
community
last question did you did you trade offs
it was your trailer yours where they
were crashing with her trailer of yours
where was a gay joke you people get
pissed off a trailer yeah it wasn't her
some trailer it's probably the you know
how I know you're gay bit from or you're
fully debatable thing right to go like
okay looking back are we saying that gay
people are funny just being themselves
or you know like what is the point of a
bit like that and you know there's all
sorts of ways to debate it you could go
like well I'm showing how immature and
idiotic these guys are I'm showing that
they're afraid of their own masculinity
or they're unsure of who they are and
I'm happy to have that debate in the
same way we can debate the trans jokes
or the parkland jokes
I got reviewed for that and I got some
people who were mad about it and other
people are like no it's just kind of a
silly you have that cutoff for no no no
we got we got about a minute okay yeah
and you did have to deal with that when
knocked-up came out which is fine I'm
totally open to the debate you're here
to promote the twentieth anniversary of
its crashing season I know I was holding
season one now I wanna be in season
three we gotta get you in season eight
oh it's on January 20th and HBO please
watch it yes and we actually kind of
covered some of this stuff in the season
so some of the climate in the in the
showbiz Sunday at 10:00 p.m. it really
is a great show thank you so check it
out and we're gonna see you all tomorrow
thank you very much Jud and Pete yes
thank you spirited conversation yes
[Music]